it's almost like a peppermint sweet
peppermint flavor like something crazy
like something different
some way different what to do with the
big bag big speaker
gq we locked in money bag yo and these
are my essentials
my first essential i can't leave the
house without some money
it's probably like twenty thousand but
anything might happen so you know i
gotta have it on me like for all
emergencies
at least for twenty none less than a
fifteen even though like we ain't been
able to like go
places and it's been so traditional i
still have been like shopping i still
just like online shopping for me and the
kids and you know and i still buy jury
most expensive thing about since
quarantine how about my girl
a lemba a lava guinea truck
this next essential is a notepad i keep
a notepad because like
sometimes my thoughts get jammed up and
it's the only way that i can just
i can i can put brakes on it and brace
myself and just
really i feel like it's better when i
see it on paper see all my my
ideas and everything on paper instead of
thinking about them and trying to like
trying to make it happen like this you
know what i'm saying even though i'm in
a studio and i don't write my music
i just steal like i got to have me a pad
no matter what put all my ideas on it
i keep it on me at all times wherever
i'm at like if i'm in traffic if i have
an idea
if i'm if i'm driving and i can't get to
the pad of course because i'm driving
i do it on voice memo on my phone just
so i can still have it and thought
when i sit down and get settled i jot it
down
tom ford cologne i got to keep this in
my backpack
at all times you never know like what mo
what might go on
outside the studio inside the studio
sometime like like now i got in i got
interviews
before the cover situation it was a
little more intimate than
what's going on right now you know what
i'm saying like i always got to have
this with me
and i got different flavors like chanel
tom ford
uh baccarat we can just keep going
i got like a peppermint it's almost like
a peppermint sweet peppermint flavor
like something crazy like something
different
some way okay i will pronounce it i
can't
you see it smell good right now
can't leave the house without water i'm
good on it water good for the skin is
good for the body it's great
it's good to stay hydrated at all times
you got to stay hydrated and i work out
a lot too so i got to have water like
i'll take water over anything i take
water over anything
how much water would you say that you
drink per day i at least drink a
gathering today i just ain't got no i'm
fresh off the road
and it's all i had with me right now but
i at least drink like a gallon a day
it's tough for sure and it's like it get
nasty sometimes it like it play with
your taste buds sometimes you really
feel like man i got the hair stone with
some flavor on it one time
you know what i'm saying but i just stay
i'm real disciplined with how i carry
myself and how it moves so
i can do it hand sand mass
you know with the whole situation going
on right now we got to have this going
on
i stay equipped at all times i actually
got a box of masses in my backpack
i keep me some hand sand 247 like
we got to take this situation way more
serious than like the world taking it
right now that's how it feels so
i want them people who take it real
serious so stay scrapped
for sure spacecraft are you having fewer
people in your studio sessions than
usual yeah most different like gotta
keep it like that but then it's so crazy
because i kind of record i like
recording with just me and the engineer
anyway but
it just made the made like gave me a
whole nother reason to really say that
like when my homeboy they try to come in
the studio i'm like nah go on chill
they're going there right quick so i do
this little verse right quick
i'm always eating them always you know
what i'm saying
i got a big appetite so i always keep
this with me
just in case anything in the food
anything gets stuck
gotta use it and people and not being a
lot of people face sometimes like
talking and
anything like that so i got to keep like
my hygiene all the way together
screen flaws it's a little more
complicated and i think like the screen
flaws
like it make your gun bleed it's just
it's a
it's like more aggressive you can take
your time with these it's like you can
be easy you know man yeah
next item portable charger
everybody needs these and like people
got it bad with stealing your chargers
and stuff too i know you'd be running
into their problem a lot anytime you
take your charge and somewhere else you
around a room full of people they quick
to pick your charge up and just roll so
i keep me up one that can stand out
can't take mine
in my business man so i got to keep my
phone charged up at all times
that's another thing too
[Music]
i like trail mixes it's just the whole
pack
hot chill doritos got to have this in
the studio
got to 24 7. trill mixes are good for
you
sometimes i i have a chef come through
and cook sometimes most of the time but
like if i'm just on a roll and i just
want to wrap and get to it quick i just
you know create a mixes chip and water
of course when you are recording in the
studio how
how long might you be in there i try to
get up in the morning
go work out i go to the studios try to
stay in the studio from like
uh i guess give you a time from like i
say 3
3 30 to probably no later than 10
o'clock i don't like to be in the studio
no later than 10 o'clock or no later
than
really no no later than 9 30. i really
go all the admitted like
at least get you one or two good songs
in a day and you're good
you don't have to rush it cuz like
coming up when i was coming up
i used to do that a lot try to rush i
gotta get like five songs done that's
only because i went as fortunate as i am
now
and i was paying for studio time like
just say forty dollars an hour
hundred dollars a hour stuff like that
you know what i'm saying it i feel like
i had to get i
get my money's worth i got to do like
five songs within this
these hours you feel them but now i just
i just unlimited
last but not least i go crazy without my
phone you know i'm a businessman
all type of stuff go on actually i got
three phones this phone this small phone
right here
this is like my personal phone it's for
the kids for their mothers my mother you
know what i'm saying just the family
phone
and this phone you looking at right here
this the money phone this this is what
make the magic happen right here so i
got to have my phones
and i got to have the charger to go with
it case anything going on
yo like i told you you locked in gq
money back yo
thanks for watching let's go until next
time